oh we're live
chairman thank you sonya
good evening everyone uh welcome to
rockford district council's remote
meeting of the executive and welcome to
anyone watching
via live stream on youtube
if i can take firstly agenda item one
apologies for absence and i understand
that no apology is for absence in fact
looking around i can see
everyone is here so that is
100 attendance um
if we go around please and sonia if you
can read out
any non-members of the executive who are
attending
we've got councillor mrs gooding and
councillor
staring
welcome to you both agenda item three
the minutes and we have two sets of
minutes
from meetings held on the 11th of august
and the 2nd of september are those
minutes accepted as an accurate record
and agreed members
chairman sorry um council sparring has
his hand up
and you're muted
i just put my hand up to indicate that i
was a non-member attending but
uh that can't go down i can't take it
down thank you
thank you thank you council sparring
right can i take it that those minutes
have been agreed
okay thank you
right we move on to agenda item four uh
to receive declarations of
interest members are there any
declarations of interest
no one is indicating as far as i can see
by
any raised hand so moving on to item
five
uh questions on notice uh from
councillors
no questions have been received members
so
we move on to item six uh mata is
referred to the executive and reports
from other committees
and there are none members which takes
us nicely on to
agenda item number seven which is the no
use
empty scheme i'm going to ask council
award portfolio holder for
strategic planning uh to introduce the
report if you'd be kind enough
please
thank you very much leader um
it's a very very uh
interesting report i'll just uh have a
brief outline of what it actually
contains
uh it's it sets a business case uh
that's been submitted to select the
local enterprise
partnership for south essex requesting
1.2 million in funding
from the getting building fund towards
starting
a no use empty scheme in south essex
the purpose of no use to
scheme is to provide secure loans to
organizations to enable them
to occupy and or redevelop
long-term vacant buildings a similar
scheme has operated for many years in
kent
to great success in addition to the 1.2
million in funding from setup
which individual south essex local
authority is being asked to contribute
up to 17 000 in match funding
the advantages of occupying stroke
redeveloping
long-term vacant buildings are numerous
but include
improving the vitality and viability of
our environments
particularly town centres supporting
local employment and avoiding the blight
and anti-social behaviour associated
with long-term vacancies
the south essex scheme aims to make as
best use
as possible of the existing expertise
held by kent county council and it is
expected that a
service level agreement will be agreed
with them
to enable them to provide advice
on the south essex scheme individual
local authorities will be expected to
identify
potential sites in their area those
wishing to benefit
from the scheme will need to apply
applications under the scheme will be
initially reviewed
by kent county council under their
existing frameworks
with the final decision whether to award
a loan
under the scheme made by the local
authority within which
the premises are located potential
premises
which might be eligible for the scheme
are yet to be identified based on an
average loan of a hundred thousand
from the kent scheme it is expected that
around
10 to 15 premises across south essex
could benefit from the scheme in its
first phase
this is likely to be two to three
premises per authority
area in south essex no projects
will be progressed unless there is
support
from the respective local authority
similarly
each authority's match funding will only
be used
if there are projects within that
authority
area therefore this is quite important
should
no suitable premises be found in a local
authority
area or that local authority determines
that it wishes not to award to any of
the premises that come
forward that authority's investment
into the screen scheme will not be
required
and would be returned the council's
investment would not be used to cross
subsidize projects in other authority
areas officers of the council's
economic development team will provide
day-to-day
oversight to the project however
final decisions as to whether to award
loans
to any rochford-based applicants
will be presented by the portfolio for
enterprise myself
at this moment to the executive for
approval
it is at this point that the council's
match funding
would become committed the risks of the
scheme are considered to be
relatively small with all applications
being subject to tried and tested
protocols
used in kent with individual risk
assessments
the council will not be obliged to award
a loan
unless it feels confident in the
soundness of the application before it
a response as to whether the business
case has been successful
is expected in november which if
successful
could lead to premises identification
and a first tranche of loans in spring
summer
2021 leader
if there's any questions i'll be happy
or i will
fill them off to marcus my assistant
director
i would say councillor ward thank you
very much indeed for that just before i
do open it up to questions
um the lead officer in this is assistant
director for patient environment marcus
hotten
um i don't know whether you want you to
add any comments before i open it up to
further questions uh i think
um councilwood has covered all the main
points so i think manchester united
emphasizes that
um the control does still rest with with
rockford i think that that's the key
thing so
so kent's really are doing merely a
screening job so
they're offering their expertise to um
risk assess each um application
and it's worth pointing out i think i've
got the stats in front of me i think
that they've
in 10 years brought in about 67 million
pounds investment to kent
and that's over 300 loans uh i think the
the bad risk is is under one percent so
you know the bad debt of that
risk is is around about the one percent
mark so you can get okay it's a low risk
investment and they've done very well i
think to weed those out for that you can
become sort of a live project so
i think all they'll be brought to the
executive will be safe
uh or you know you're going to think 100
safe but you know
uh in terms of risk they've been managed
um particularly well by kent before we
even get to see them
but the ultimate control over we
actually want to keep up with our
finances
is still the executive at that stage
thank you thank you very much indeed
marcus i'll now move to questions from
members councillor fd uh thank you
chairman
um mark has actually answered a lot of
my questions there there's just one
video that's
on there now as kent will be doing the
due diligence
for the loan applications who will
actually be giving the go ahead
for the loans would it be an officer
from
rochford or would it be someone from
kent no it would be ourselves so
the executive i mean i think because it
it's as you said it's only two or three
applications
and we took the view that actually um
you know it'd be worthy of bringing a
report back each time to executive
if there was 50 or 60 we might want to
have a different mechanism but when it's
only two or three that i think you'll be
considering
it seems uh appropriate to bring them
back to executives each time
okay actually to the executive the other
thing is what's the real difference
between this and the bounce back loan
would this be easier to get than a
bounce-back loan or
um i don't know if it'd be easier
just do something yeah it's different
than obviously it's it's
a secured loan against the sort of
actual investment in the property so
it's a bit more considered i think in
that sense so it's
a it's a it's a you know it is it is
specifically just for empty
properties and what they do they assess
the likelihood of being able to repay
that back
so it's a keyword loan so there's a
little more sort of subtle
um i guess hurdles to jump
in the bounce back line thank you thanks
councillor simon smith thank you
um you you mentioned that the default
rate was very low
but just in the news the last couple of
days with
uh mentioning the grants that have been
given out
as a result of kobet there has been a
significant amount of
fraud potentially is there any
information
about around fraud from uh experiences
so far thank you
i won't profess to know the ins and outs
of the scheme um
uh to the last detail but i mean again
these are well thought out schemes for
understanding that you know that they um
they do risk assess and there's due
diligence that's done before
it's brought to us and certainly naomi
has over
seen that as well um we'll take another
look at that if it needs to be risk
assessed
by ourselves as well but my
understanding is that
um their ability to manage risk and
consider the ability for
them to pay back the lunch is secured um
it is still
considerable thank you
marcus and i see that our section 151
officer naomi lucas has raised her hand
so
naomi over to you
thank you thank you chair um i i'd just
like to add
in terms of council smith's comments
that i think the risk of
um fraud or um
in this particular scheme is
particularly low
um the government schemes have been in
the news over the past
um few days have obviously been open to
kind of speculative applications and
due to the volume and the sort of quick
turnaround period
and there has been um obviously an
additional risk of
fraud although we've obviously done
everything we can to mitigate that
locally
um but in this particular case it's a
very targeted scheme and there will be
rigorous checks undertaken of each
individual business so i'd say the risk
of fraud in this particular instance is
very very low
thank you naomi that's extremely helpful
um are there any other members with
questions
i'm not seeing any other hands
no in that case um there are
two recommendations um of paragraphs
1.1 and 1.2 what i'll do is i'll read
them out
and then we have a decision to make
whether we vote on them separately or
take them together
but i will read them first at the first
one is to ratify the council's agreement
to participate in a no use empty scheme
across south essex authorities subject
to a joint bid for getting a building
fund financing from south
east local enterprise partnership sell
it as it's known for short
being successful and the second
recommendation
is to agree that the council can invest
up to 17 000
pounds in match funding towards loans
to develop suitable empty properties
identified within the rockford district
area the moneys will be held by south
end borough council
as the accountable body for the scheme
and he's considered
to strongly align with its wider
economic objectives
and priorities now members
are you happy to vote on those two
recommendations together
i would assume that you are unless i see
anyone
signaling to the country
and i can't see any signaling so
voting will be done on those two
recommendations
together and it will be done by roll
call of names
when sonia calls out your name please
indicate if you wish to have a recorded
vote
and then whether you are voting for or
against the recommendation
or if you wish to abstain sonia
thank you uh councillor fd um
no to recorded vote and for the
recommendation thank you
cancer mrs rowe thank you sonya no and
for
councillor smith no recorded vote
for the recommendation council award
sonia there's no n4 for me thank you
cancer webb thank you no and for the
recommendation please
counselor williams uh thank you sonya
that's no
n4 thank you and counselor
thank you sonya no and for
chairman that's unanimously uh approved
so that is unanimously approved both of
those recommendations
right moving on to agenda item number
eight
uh which is a projects program
and if i can ask our strategic director
angela hutchings pleased to report on
the project's report at
item 8 please thank you thank you
chairman
this is the the regular report of the
programme management office in respect
of those projects which report
into the executive so that's the ict
migration project which is a gold the
beagle event project which is silver and
the connect
program which is also gold checking
those in reverse order
um for the connect program members will
recall that
um a report was brought to this meeting
on the 8th of july
uh this project has now begun in earnest
a project manager has been installed to
begin
and members you can expect a full report
um in the next quarter
in relation to the beagle event again
also on the 8th of july
i brought a report to the executive uh
indicating that i would be reviewing the
viability of the beagle event in a
post-govid world and a report will be
brought back to this forum in december
and members the the wallacy project is a
separate agenda item
for later discussion um the the
third uh project the ict migration
project is a closeout report
um provided this evening um following
which the
project will be removed from the remit
of pmo
uh and the assistant director for
transformation and customer is here if
you have any questions in respect of
that closeout report thank you chairman
thank you very much indeed angela just
before i open it up for questions are
there any other members or officers that
wish to
add further information before we open
it up
again i can't see any hands so that
members
any questions of that report
no i can't see any uh any questions so
in that case there is one recommendation
on paragraph 1.1 of the
and that is to note the closure of the
ict migration project
and update on the connect program is
that noted members
that's it no thank you
thank you moving on to agenda item
number nine
which is the hms beagle heritage project
at wallacey island
i'm going to ask angela hutchings
strategic director
to please introduce the report
thank you again chairman as i mentioned
a moment ago
this is the grant funding which the
council made to rspb
to support infrastructure on the
wallasey island
nature reserve to promote the district's
historic links to
hms beagle works have been completed
and come in under budget uh a viewing
platform has been
installed at the sea wall and benches at
lagoons which are sort of equidistant
between the car park
and the sea wall the lagoons are named
darwin stokes and fitzroy and they are
part of a beagle trail which has been
established on
the reserve which enables um visitors to
follow the trail
um from the car park through the down to
the lagoons and down onto
to the sea wall interpretation boards
have been commissioned um
they are yet to be installed we're
waiting for the printer
but they are finalized and everything
else is in place including new signage
maps improved car parking and servicing
for
temporary toilets to be provided by rspb
there is a small underspend of just over
ten thousand pounds
um which um falls
to be returned under the normal course
of events to
to the council um but the request from
rspbs that they would use that under
spend on a hiding screen near to the
lagoon to enhance the visitor experience
it's outside the remit of the original
grant funding chairman and that's why
it's come back to this
forum for discussion if members are
minded to approve it
then the rspb will continue to use that
um that underspend if members are not
minded to approve it then the moneys
will be returned to reserves
thank you thank you very much indeed
angela and again before i open it up for
questions
uh i would invite any other members who
wish to
make a contribution on that report
council rafting
thank you chairman um i'm very pleased
that the isp
as rspb has managed to bring this in
under budget
and having the money back
going to general reserves what i think
will actually
be nice to be used for new projects in
the future um
because they have brought it in under
budget and that and we've done they've
done what we've asked them to do
just let's say that thank you thank you
council fd council aboard
thank you leader um just a question i i
wondered i noticed that you've got the
maps and signage boards
are are they going to be available from
our site to download
um because obviously we want to try and
look a bit of connectivity
and so you know if people want to
download them to their phones or ipads
will that be available
chairman if you're happy for me to
answer that question
um the interpretation boards themselves
are physical
explanations of of what the visitor is
actually looking at so they have
plans that are adjacent to the landscape
but what they will include is a qr code
which takes a visitor to the discover
2020 website
and on that website there's a link to
the digital cgi funded by the national
lottery
which gives a digital three-dimensional
view of the of the beagle both as she
would have looked
um in the southern seas and also how she
would have looked um
moored in pakistan pool and so the
experience is enhanced if you access
that website
from the actual viewpoints um but you
can access it from the comfort of your
own living room also
thank you thank you angela thank you to
thad council award that
that um should be launched uh in the
next
week or 10 days and the interpretation
boards are intended to be
in situ in around the same time table
there'll be a soft covered secure
launch um so that members and residents
can
be advised that the um the uh
installations are complete
um and then we will do a formal um award
at some point later on in the
in the year thank you thank you very
much indeed angela
any more questions members
i can't see any hands um
councillor webb
thank you i'm just wondering if there's
any possibility of match funding
for the hyde that's been proposed i
understand it'll cost about 10
000 pounds which i guess is good value
if you're interested in watching birds
um but surely there must be other match
funding sources that maybe we could look
into rather than just paying for the
whole lot ourselves
it's just council web i think that's a
really good point
um i will come in there uh with my own
comments and i really applaud the fact
of what has been produced here and i
applaud even more
that through prudent cost
benefit it has come in significantly
under budget
there is for me a principle that when
something
comes in under budget um we applaud the
factories coming under budget
we don't actually find a way of spending
uh the money
in a different way and that doesn't for
me take away
uh the value of having a hide and a path
leading to the hide um i want to make
that absolutely clear
but for me there is a principle here
that we applaud
and underspend and we
don't find another way of spending the
money it is as simple as that it's a
principle for me
rather than the actual issue so i'm
afraid i will not
be supporting the recommendation that i
want to clearly understand that
in no way minimizes you know the
importance
of finding a way perhaps to fund the
hide
perhaps in a different way um but we are
after all
considering this project uh we're not
looking at
another project within this report so uh
i'd like to make that quite clear
councillor fd uh come back on that point
chairman there's nothing to stop isp be
asking for going down the route of us
seeking funding at a later date if they
want to
with us again it comes to us the gift to
give it or not
absolutely and you know i would applaud
that and i think that answers your point
doesn't it counselor web
yeah okay all right any other
members wish to raise any questions
okay in that case uh there is one
recommendation set out of paragraph 1.1
of the report and that is i'll read it
out
to agree that the unspent part of a 50
000 pounds capital grant made to rspb by
the council for the creation
of facilities to commemorate hms beagle
be used by the rspb as set out in
paragraph
3.8 and 3.9 of the report
now voting will be done by a roll call
of names when sonia calls out your name
these indicate if you wish to have a
recorded vote and then whether you are
voting for
or against the recommendation or if you
wish to abstain
sonia thank you
uh council refugee no recording votes on
you and against the recommendation thank
you
councillor mrs rowe thank you sonia no
and against
councillor smith thank you no
recorded vote and against
council award
no and against
councillor webb thank you no and against
that's um that was sort of unanimously
uh not approved
thank you sonya uh and as you heard
there um
unanimously not approved uh and i'm
afraid that uh
that's therefore not agreed now
that concludes the business for this
evening um
thank you uh members thank you
non-members of the executive and thank
you
to members of the public that may be
looking in this evening
and i'm now at 1956 that's four minutes
straight
at